un chantier de déconstruction et de
réhabilitation le club le village à
montigny le bretonneux se refait une
beauté
le complexe dédié au sport de raquette
date de 1984 il faut donc le remettre
aux normes
prochaine étape transformation et
aménagement des locaux terrains de
tennis et badminton seront déplacés sur
une table couverte c'est à dire d'abord
la dalle tennis peuvent ils enfin délice
babington qui ce qui va être cool et
ensuite l'armature métallique qui va
recouvrir donc ça sera complètement
renfermé ensuite il ya toute la partie
ici interne donc de tout ce qui était la
salle de réception aussi ici vous êtes
dans un hall qui sera le hall d'accueil
de nouvel établissement
la première étape du chantier concernait
des travaux de déconstruction l'une des
halles a été entièrement démontées
l'autre va être réhabilité on va
renforcer la structure bois et puis donc
la mettre aux normes et de la mettre en
disposition
qu'elle soit complètement exportable
cette nouvelle halle accueillera les
terrains de deux nouveautés du complexe
le futsal et le padel de nouvelles
pratiques sportives pour rendre le club
le village plus attractif qui
corresponde aujourd'hui à des demandes
très très fort de la part des
utilisateurs est toujours dans l'optique
de
2 dédié aux sports loisirs le nouveau
complexe devrait être livré courant 2022
le montant des travaux s'élève à 6,7
millions d'euros une partie du budget
sera financée par une opération
immobilière des logements qui seront
construits à la place de l'ancienne
halle